there you go on that note i want to dive
into a super sensitive and important
topic
which is actually confusion and this has
been one thing that i do really fall
put on us and there's there's a plan
coming here for an article follow-up
especially as we get close to caps 2
which is coming and i'm going to talk a
little bit about what i can about what
the improvements are what we've learned
about how machine learning
and machines approach chess terms of the
information we can tease out
how well you play with your knights and
your bishops and some really cool stuff
that can be insights for people
so caps2 is going to be even better but
let's bring up caps and talk a little
bit about it right now
we've got a full screen capture right
here
for those that are with us again i am
reading chat please save your questions
if you've got some hard-hitting
questions for the q a portion about
cheat detection other things
please uh please save them so um
we've we've got our accuracy percentage
and my producer's working on a little
bit of a zoom in there which is awesome
here we go
so you can see in this particular game i
lost i lost and still had 96.2 god story
of my life
to 98.3 right so a lot of people
look at that at times and they think
that that means cheating
they think that 98.3 is a game that only
the world's best could play so certainly
someone
who's not the world's best can't play
that kind of game in a blitz game
right so again superficially
that type of opinion has been brought to
actually
a lot of a lot of us here at chess.com
and i
and i faced it directly because it's
confusion because we launched a product
that had a a score given of accuracy
right and that the natural human thing
to deter from that as well 100
must be perfect right 98 is close to
perfect right
so not untrue but what i want to clarify
is that
caps in and of itself first of all when
you run it it's running on our server
and the default depth that most people
get it at which is what i just got it at
is actually running at a superficial
analysis of 18 and 7 seconds at times
rather than a full report
that gives you that gives you a massive
amount of time
if i run this depth report right now and
actually wait for five minutes which
very few of you do that raise your hand
you know you're guilty
okay it would actually change
both the depth and the specific outputs
here so first thing i would challenge
you to do is understand
that the basic purpose of caps was to
give you a very
quick hit into the blunders made and to
change something in chess that was very
hard for new players to understand this
is the main message i'm trying to
deliver with caps for team members
watching that we can cut this as a video
to share we face so many new members to
the chess community with our domain name
awesome we're super fortunate right that
a lot of times we underappreciate
how many new people are playing chess
and and don't understand the chess
ranking system
if i say someone is 1600 or 2700 they go
like out of what
2700 out of 3 000. well not exactly it's
on an elo band and the elo band has a
calculus that's designed to bring down
the curve to prevent you from getting
better than people down low so you can't
just rating for them to get over three
thousand
right that's okay so that's one thing
about elo okay so how does it work then
to measure people so what is the 2700
then does that mean you're the best
well actually no people have gotten over
2 800 but eventually they're going to
slow down it's not a true indicator of
magnus skulls and strength that he can't
reach 2900 you know why because he can't
get rating points anymore from 2600 so
how good really is he
right oh my god i could go on so we try
to explain to people how good is my
individual game
how did i play right and you can't
really
explain this to people with a rating
system in chess especially when it's
measured and limited
on the strength of your opponent okay
get with me so what caps is
is a self-measurement between you and
whatever engine strength you delegate
that's why i first said you can get a
stronger engine if you run three to five
minutes server side
but even at a superficial level it's a
pure comparison not based on how hard
your opponent's moves were defined
not based on maybe the opening that you
knew was super deep so gave you a higher
score than before
your opponent blunders all the time
which just makes it easy for you to get
a higher score
right none of that is really relevant to
how well it's be
that's all like things that are outside
of your control
but a cap score is giving you a
measurement of zero to whatever engine
we had let's say the engine is perfect
okay how well you matched up it's not
necessarily t1
quick hit analysis but a little bit a
blunder check and to tell you
and again here's what i'm getting to the
score a new player can understand
oh it's ranked 0 to 100 that's like i
got an
a everybody in the world knows a scoring
system from school
we all do oh okay that's like i got a b
that's like i got a c right and so
what we did this as a feature not as a
cheat detection tool
we can like cap it and clip it and ship
it right there to people wondering
caps is not chess.com cheat detection
zero caps has zero to do with chess.com
cheat detection
in fact if anybody is like thinking
they're developing a cheat detection
tool based on any one game approach
or based on analysis that doesn't take
indicators of other forms of measurement
of how hard the moves were to find
they're doing something that's
superficial and reckless and if you are
out there making cheat accusations based
on your opponent's cap score
you're wrong and it's not really fair
and it is against our bylaws
so why do we have it again it was a way
to help people who don't understand the
chess ranking system in a snapshot view
how well they played quickly in an
individual game
doesn't even have the deepest engine
it's a 0-100 marker that doesn't
totally take into into account how well
your opponent played which is what you
have to do if you're weathering
if you're evaluating whether someone
cheated and again the elo system
is too complicated for people to
understand quickly especially the
audience that we bring in with our
domain name
so this is the long-winded goal of this
show here is that caps forevermore as of
this point
should not be considered part of your
cheat detection and do not use it to
accuse people for cheat detection
now yes if someone understands a little
more about our algorithm
statisticians out there i know we have
very smart people in the audience and if
you aggregated a cap score
over someone's 100 games and
over those 100 games took into account
some of the other secret things that the
sauce things we do that can take into
account strength and difficulty
of some stuff you might you might be
getting closer
okay but a lot of reckless accusations
have been made including by parents of
young talented players they know who
they are
and they continue to be aggressive and
accuse things and make themselves a
vigilante cheat detection
based on information that is actually
not accurate and again you can blame
chess.com but why do we have the score
there again we
this is this is a blog that is coming
when we release caps 2 to combine with
this video
but the goal of this was to address caps
2 is to help people
who don't understand the chess ranking
system quickly how they did
and to allow people to quickly see the
key moments of the game because what we
can evaluate quickly with caps even at
the superficial engine
and again remember i said if you want
deeper caps run the longer one what you
can evaluate is the
is the the move evaluation swing someone
made a move that changed the evaluation
by this
we can classify that as a blunder and it
affects the cap score
but but that is purely indicative of of
an individual game not something that
could ever be used in
a respectful way to make cheat
accusations
it's not a part of chess.com's cheat
detection and it is mostly designed
i'm sorry this is disappointing to help
people who don't understand the chess
rating system quickly whether they got
an a or a d on their game
and that's really what it's about it's
kind of a fun tool all right it's not a
part of our cheat detection
danny out